Who's there!
Diego!
this can't be right
what the hell did we do now?
What was that? the end of the world
November 25th 1963 Dallas ten days earlier
I need to find my family
all right first off I want to say we
brought the end of the world back here
with us oh my god again my cult is gonna
be so pissed I told him we had until
2019 we have until Monday
everything in
our life is connected from the plot to
assassinate the president. that can't be
a coincidence
none of us are supposed to be here right we know
something changes in the timeline
and we have to make it right again before everyone
and everything we know is dead
Who are those guys?
They're not here to sell vacuums. The
Commission will hunt us down wherever
and whenever we go
I need a spotter what does that like a
wingman?
You don't know anything about me. I know
everything you are an open book written
full of very dumb children
Klaus, is Ben here?
no unfortunately ghosts can't time
travel are you kidding me
all right quick rundown Luther
super-strength class can commune with
the dead Allison can rumor anyone to do
anything except she never uses it
I heard a rumor you punched yourself in the face.
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my umbrella Academy's season 2
trailer Netflix just dropped a whole
bunch of new footage so we'll break it
down it's been a while since season 1
but I will be doing some videos for the
season 2 episodes later this month when
all the episodes drop so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos if you never read the
comic book or you've completely
forgotten what happened during season 1
because it's been so long they're
basically a parody of Marvel's x-men
like you have a gifted school for
youngsters a version of Professor X but
it's so much weirder so they're like
that not-safe-for-work
x-men and you even have Kitty Pryde one
of the former x-men from the x-men
movies the big thing with season 2 is
that now that they've time shifted or
they time traveled back into the 1960s
and they're moving through the comic
book story but they are changing a lot
about the comics that they're adapting
the volume they're adapting for season
two is called umbrella academy Dallas as
in Dallas Texas as you see during the
trailer during the 1960's there are a
couple really big things that happened
in Dallas during the 1960's that they
referenced during the timeline here in
the trailer so when number 5 jumps in
and is like where am I what's going on
here everything seems like it's in chaos
the person there tells him that the
world's going to end November 25th 1963
the reason why that date might sound
familiar to you is because it's just a
couple days after JFK was assassinated
in Dallas Texas so obviously in the
trailer you kind of see them reference
it it'll be a big part of the seasons
plot but then you see all these Soviet
communists invading so apparently
whatever happens to lead to JFK's
assassination in the aftermath it causes
the cold war with the Soviet Union to
turn into a full-blown war
mutually-assured nuclear destruction
with that giant mushroom cloud going off
like they said at the end of season 1
they failed to prevent the end of the
world and now they've just postponed it
and has followed them into the past
they're changing a lot about the comic
book plot of
academy dallas so if you did read the
comic book there will be a lot of
differences there's way more time
shifting it gets way more complicated so
these are just simplifying a lot of that
storyline the big twist at the end of
the trailer is them meeting the younger
version of Hargreaves who's still alive
at this point with the younger version
of Pogo who's still alive he was killed
during season 1 along with Hargreaves
they tell him about who he is what the
school is the Umbrella Academy itself
and why he needs to adopt those seven
children so that's how he winds up
knowing which special children to adopt
during season one there were 43 all born
on the same day around the world so he
goes around adopting seven special ones
but now we know it's because they told
him which ones to adopt you need to
adopt all of us that's why during season
one you see him inspecting all the
babies with that special monocle just to
make sure that it's the right ones that
he's adopting if you're not really
familiar with the characters or you
skipped a lot of season one Luther's
number one he's super strong he also had
his head transplanted onto the body of a
gorilla after he had an accident in
outer space
number two is Diego he's just really
awesome with knives number three is
Alison who has the power of suggestion
using rumors she can make people do what
she wants if she repeats the phrase I
heard a rumor before she says the action
that she wants them to take like the end
of the trailer where she says I heard a
rumor quote-unquote that you punched
yourself in the face and then he punches
himself in the face at the end of season
one Vanya actually slit her throat to
prevent her from using her power but it
seems that she gets her voice and her
powers back during season 2
number four is Klaus he's usually super
high but he can also talk to the dead
the goes that they referenced during the
trailer that keeps following him around
and followed him around during season
one is actually the ghost of one of
their former brothers in the Umbrella
Academy program number six he died a
long time ago though the other cool side
effect of Klaus is necromancy powers is
that he can actually channel the powers
of the Dead spirits if they has special
powers themselves so these powers aren't
Klaus as natural powers they're number
sixes powers even though he's dead he's
still able to use them number five is
the time traveler he drives most of the
plot during season one season 2 his
powers are self explanatory he also
worked for the Commission briefly
they're the same ones that are chasing
them down during season 2 they were
kind of the antagonists during season
one they're kind of like sinister
versions of ty
cops in the world of the Umbrella
Academy they try to protect the timeline
but they're also not above manipulating
the timeline to benefit their
organization number 7 is Vanya the white
violin she has sonic based abilities and
is super powerful in terms of x-men
Marvel Easter eggs she'd be like an
omega-level mutant she's also played by
Kitty Pryde as I said from the x-men
movies I don't know how much they're
changing her storyline during season 2
from the comics because she actually has
amnesia after this big catastrophe at
the end of season 1 so she doesn't
remember going full evil to try and
destroy the world it's kind of hard to
tell if she has amnesia based on this
trailer footage but it seems like she's
pretty chill so I'm assuming that she
might have a little bit of amnesia just
not remember that moment the whole thing
with the end of the season though is
that number 5 had actually intended on
jumping them back in time into their
child bodies so that they could just
restart and try to save the world again
instead though it seems like they all
just wind up in the past straight up
Klaus becomes a cult leader like he is
that funny moment in the trailer when
they find out the world's going to end
in 1963 and he gets all upset oh I told
my cult that the world wasn't going to
end till 2019 Allison seems like she
gets into some sort of romance and
involved in the civil rights movement
Luther becomes a fighter for money he
actually takes his jacket off too they
spent way more money on the special
effects budget or maybe that's just some
prosthetics that they put on him number
6 is still dead but he's still
ultimately following Klaus around
because he's the only one who can
perceive him like they have that funny
slap fight there so if you were to walk
by Klaus on the street there it would
look like he's slapping nothing Diego
winds up in a mental institution it
looks like the girl that he winds up
getting into a relationship with also
follows him around so she becomes a bit
of a character during season 2 as well
then Vanya seems like she is driving
around with his family maybe trying to
get back to the rest of the group but
like I said the people chasing them
through the trailer with the guns are
the Commission the whole joke about
Diego being a very dumb book written for
children is just the writers making a
joke about the Umbrella Academy comic
books that the show is based on in just
comic books in general books written for
children haha quote-unquote some of this
will seem very different from the comic
book plot it's not going to be quite so
complicated as the comic book story but
if you spotted any big Easter eggs that
I didn't mention during the video just
let me know in the comments there's
really cool weird stuff in the comic
books that I'm hoping will show up in
the episodes the season is going to
premiere july 31st they'll be dropping
all the episodes the big stuff that's
coming up after this is actually going to
be the boys season 2 episodes in early
September then we have the mandalorian
season 2 episodes from Disney Plus
then we have all the big Marvel Disney
Plus shows they haven't given us a full
schedule for the rest of the year on
that stuff but there'll be a bunch of
big stuff happening the second half of
the year so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when I post them every
one click here for that brand new
trailer for the boys season 2 and click
here for that Michael Keaton Batman
deleted scene from crisis on Infinite
Earths thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys
tonight!